we've got breaking news financier
Jeffrey Epstein was taken to the
infirmary after he was found injured in
his New York City jail cell law
enforcement is investigating mola
lanka's here with this breaking story
Mulla what happened well Gail as you
mentioned CBS News has learned that
Jeffrey Epstein was found injured on the
floor of his jail cell and according to
a source officials believe Epstein
attempted suicide earlier this week he
was found on the floor crying semi lucid
and depressed we're told he was treated
in the infirmary of the prison and his
injuries do not appear to be
life-threatening the financier is being
held at the Metropolitan Correctional
Center in New York City where he was
already isolated on suicide watch when
the incident occurred earlier this week
investigators are checking internal
cameras to learn more as much as they
can
Epstein was arrested earlier this month
as you remember on sex trafficking and
conspiracy charges for allegedly
sexually abusing underage girls from
2002 to 2005 Epstein pleaded not guilty
but was denied bail because of his
overseas connections his extraordinary
wealth and as the judge put it his risk
to the public
Epstein pled guilty to soliciting for
soliciting a minor for prostitution in
Florida back in 2008 and although he
served 13 months he avoided a
potentially longer jail sentence after a
controversial plea deal that many
criticized as being too lenient lat
alright MOA you've been covering the
story from the beginning we'll look for
your reporting throughout the course of
the week thank you